in 1802 the great scientists and
explorer Alexander von Humboldt went up
a mountain and came down with an idea
that changed ecology Humboldt was
determined to reach the summit of
Chimborazo a 60 300 meter high volcano
in Ecuador which at the time was thought
to be the highest mountain in the world
a chasm prevented the Explorer from
reaching the peak but ever the
naturalist all the way up and all the
way back down
Humboldt dutifully collected
measurements five years later he
published his findings from Chimborazo
and other mountains in an epic drawing
tableau physique as he called it depicts
what was then a novel concept that
climate is an organizing principle of
life shaping the distinct communities of
plants and animals found at different
altitudes and latitudes climate change
affects all kinds of aspects of the
world it affects water it affects ice it
affects communities of plants and
animals and scientists who are studying
the impacts of climate change are
finding that Humboldt's holistic
approach drawing on many different
disciplines to understand how the
physical and biological worlds interact
is really the key to understanding how
climate change is transforming our world
even without the historical perspective
from Humboldt it's plain to see that
global warming is laying siege to
Chimborazo the volcanoes glaciers
overall have lost 20% of their surface
area since the 1980s retreating ice
reveals soil rock and gravel ready to be
colonized by vegetation newly verdant
slopes are popping up higher and higher
on tropical mountains like Chimborazo
throughout the world so a team decided
to use Humboldt data as he mapped it on
Pablo physique to figure out how much
plants have migrated up the slope of
Chimborazo over the past 200 years the
team selected 51 high-altitude plant
taxa that Humboldt described in his
tableau physique and other works from
the Andes and climbed much of the way up
the mountain themselves to see where
those plants now grow
while Humboldt had recorded an upper
limit for seed plants of 4,600 meters in
2012 the scientists found that the upper
limit was nearly 50 200 meters other
lower living species had moved upslope
by an average of more than 500 meters
since humbles climb but not everyone
thinks Humboldt stata is reliable enough
to base new research on one group notes
that Humboldt spent just a few hours on
Chimborazo that he didn't collect above
3,600 meters and his sampling wasn't
systematic in fact they argue that
Humboldt transpose measurements he made
on a nearby volcano onto sana because
well
Chimborazo was the more famous mountain
so was Humboldt wrong to reconcile the
measurements scientists recently went to
antis Onam and using humboldt data from
the tableau physique mac how much the
plants on ant asana had moved upslope so
far they found that one species senecio
Novalis climb more than 200 vertical
meters in step with the rising snow line
so the rise is perhaps not as dramatic
as originally thought based on Humboldt
tableau but it still clearly shows a
steep jump
well climate change also is affecting
water that flows down the mountain to
communities downslope in some of the
communities in Chimborazo the flow in
the main irrigation channel on the side
of the mountain has fallen by about 50
percent in the last couple of decades
other parts of the mountain wells have
dried up and there's at least a
suspicion that this has a lot to do with
the shrinking of the glaciers
researchers hope to take their updated
understanding of Chimborazo x' glaciers
and vegetation into a predictive model
which would forecast how continuing
glacial retreat will make water scarce
err and less reliable for downstream
users not just on Chimborazo but on
glacial mountains everywhere to
accurately reflect the effect of climate
change on Chimborazo Humboldt's classic
drawing needs a revision
but his findings continue to energize
the latest group of researchers
following in his footsteps
[Music]
[Music]
you